400 pound NYPD robot gets tryout in
Times Square subway station the K-5 it's
from a california-based maker night
scope night scope describes it as a
quote fully autonomous outdoor security
robot the bot will only get better and
night scope don't think knightscope
didn't have that conversation don't
think knightscope didn't go by the way
this is only the demo you know all the
cops and Eric Adams are sitting in a in
a conference room and night scope
whatever the hell that is
based in California night scope has a
video monitor on the wall and it's just
Transformer style Bots pinning people to
the wall and chucking them and
I'm telling you the cops are ear to ear
Smiles Eric Adams is like and how much
will these guys do this for they're like
it's nine an hour we can maybe get it
down to six maybe the Bots that attack
people will be 15.